welcome this everybody to the Macmillan
Center this afternoon for the coca-cola
world fund lecture this is an endowed
lecture it was established in 1992 by
Roberto wet sarah former chair and CEO
of coca-cola and a graduate of yale
college class of nineteen fifty-three to
support into the intersecting endeavors
among specialists in international
relations international law and the
management of international enterprises
and organizations it's it's co-sponsored
by asset that Macmillan Center the
School of Management and the law school
and I'm delighted today that Marwan
mawashi is going to be giving the
coca-cola lecture ambassador Malaysia is
a Jordanian national whose career has
spanned the areas of diplomacy
development civil society and
communications he started out as a
journalist at the Jordan Times and from
nineteen eighty five to nineteen ninety
he served in the Ministry of Planning in
Jordan in 1995 which was a propitious
time or what people thought was a
propitious time in the Middle East and
the Arab Palestinian relations in
particular he he really came into his
own the previous year Jordan had signed
a peace agreement with Israel the
negotiations at Oslo appeared to be
heading for resolution and Jordan
established diplomatic ties with israel
and Marwan Masha was the first
ambassador of course that that November
things took a tragic turn when it's up
Robin was assassinated and arguably the
most promising window of opportunity for
middle east regional peace closed as a
result of that but Milan was a very
important player in those developments
and then
so he opened Jordan's embassy in Israel
then and was involved in mediating those
events and in 1997 he came to Washington
where he served as as ambassador and
negotiated the first free trade
agreement between the u.s. and any Arab
country then he went back to Jordan
where he became foreign minister and
again became deeply immersed in the
peace process in 2004 he became deputy
prime minister responsible for
government reform a subject that is very
dear to his heart that he is a subject
in his first book which I'll say
something about in a minute and also
informs what he's he's his present
concerns he became deputy prime minister
in 2004 and led to and led the effort to
produce a ten-year development strategy
that included among other things major
recommendations on political and
economic reform employment education and
training he in nineteen 2008 he
published a book with yale press called
the arab center the promise of
moderation and it was actually just when
that book was about to come out that i
first got to know Marwan Masha it's it's
a remarkable book and a very courageous
book arguing for a rich understanding of
moderation and the need for it in Arab
politics and also arguing for government
for for reform in in our politics it was
widely acclaimed that book when it was
published Scott McCloud of time the the
Cairo bureau chief said this is one of
the most important books on the Middle
East required reading for everyone
interested in finding solutions to the
many problem so that the region's faces
today Hanan Ashrawi said Marwan washes
not just a witness but also an active
participant and shaper of the realities
in the middle
and she went on to praise this book and
I I remember we Marwan gave them
lectures here to make melon center in
connection with the publication of that
book and I remember talking to him about
the need for reform and this was 2008
the end of the Bush administration which
certainly had not advanced the cause of
Middle East peace and I remember a
conversation which my one may well have
forgotten but we were talking about the
need for reform in in the middle era
politics and the importance of regional
efforts and and I made that kind of
offer off-the-cuff remark that first
term American administrations tend not
to want to do very much in the Middle
East for reasons having to do with
American domestic politics and that it
therefore would probably take waiting
for a second term administration to
expect anything much if anything
constructive out of the US and Marlins
comment was there isn't enough time to
wait for a second US administration and
if that was among the many prescient
things that that he had to say at that
time and so now he has a new book coming
out also from Yale press called the
second Arab Awakening the battle for
pluralism and it's not there many books
about the the Arab Spring now sort of
the chasing yesterday's newspaper
headings variety and and this book is
not that it takes a much more medium run
medium to long run view of the sorts of
changes that are needed in Arab
societies and politics in order for the
second Arab Awakening to produce the
kind of pluralism that's going to
sustain democratic politics that is his
principal concern now and that is the
subject of his lecture today which is
called the second Arab Awakening and the
battle for pluralism more one welcome
back to yell
in Thank You Vera really a most graceful
introduction that I don't deserve I want
to thank you thank the Macmillan center
and the coca-cola world fund and of
course he had for having me back this is
becoming very familiar room to me and I
give a lot of lectures here and it's
always a pleasure to be back at here in
fact I think Ian I will credit in for my
second book because we had a
conversation two years ago or three
years ago now when I started teaching
political of course on the need for
political reform at Yale just about the
time that the uprising started in
Tunisia and in Egypt I remember my first
class was in January 21st 2011 and of
course Egypt started on january twenty
fifth and I had a conversation with Ian
and he said you know you have to update
your book your first book to reflect
these changes or maybe even write a
second one and sure sure enough I think
partly a result of my lectures here at
he'll give me that the stamina and the
structure to write my second book so
what are we three years later now what
are we to make of what has happened in
the Middle East you know I remember the
euphoria that we all had when it first
started when everybody rushed to call it
an Arab Spring and I also see the
indifference today that many have when
everybody is also rushing to call it an
Arab winter so which is it is it an Arab
Spring is it an Arab autumn in Egypt is
it an Arab inferno in Syria what is it
it all depends
my view on the lens that you use to look
at this historical transformation and if
somebody chooses a lens of three years
then of course there isn't much to be
enthusiastic about but I think that many
of us forget that historical
transformations never ever took place in
three years ever Germany was a
dictatorship until nineteen forty-five
Spain and Portugal were not democracies
until the late seventies Poland until 89
and the list goes on I don't need to
tell you and in no case that a country
or region was able to just transform
itself from an autocracy to a democracy
overnight and in some cases it never did
it's not given that once
transformational processes happen that
the end result is necessarily democracy
everywhere you look some people will
reach there some people will not and
others will struggle along the way but
among all the turmoil and killings that
is going on in the Middle East today
sometimes I think it is difficult to
remember that there are already some
positive developments that are going on
some that are not so positive but in all
cases lessons to be drawn from what we
have seen so far I think the departure
point at least to me the departure point
of all this is that the Arab world was
living in a state of artificially
induced stability this was not a region
that was stable naturally this was not a
region that enjoyed prosperity and
stability just because of natural causes
stability was artificially induced by
brute force
part of government's who are ruling over
this region by brute force and when the
lid finally came you know out naturally
you are going to see all these
developments take place in a very messy
way but it's a process that needed to
start because you want will not ever
reach stability in the end natural
stability without such a process
starting and therefore you know to those
that dream of going back to the status
quo an argument and there are many of
them in the Arab world today that argue
that it is better to go back to the
status quo ante well guess what that is
impossible impossible and the question
to ask from now on is not to go back to
the status quo but how to go about
developing or working for a process that
will end up in pluralistic societies in
democratic societies even if it takes
not months or years but decades I still
remember the last time I was here in
this auditorium I made a bold prediction
which I don't think was very well
received by the audience and I said that
I predict a peak of support for the
Islamists in the Arab world that was
only last year said i don't think the
Islam's will from now on do as well as
they did in Egypt Tunisia Morocco
anywhere else they want elections and at
the time people looked you know at me
with wide eyes and I claim today that
this is indeed the case this is the case
because of several factors that were
true then and Arturo now Islamists were
the only organized for
that were artificially kept out of the
system by Arab governments and as they
were kept out they could promise people
the moon and they did without having to
put their promises to the test once they
came into power they were proven to be
no better or worse than any other
political force on the scene their
ability to translate their very famous
slogan Islam is the solution to detailed
programs that would you know deal with
such issues as an employment or
inclusive growth or investments or what
have you of course were lacking and as a
result in a place like Egypt where
Egyptian society is conservative and is
religious but that same society does not
want anyone to tell it how to practice
that religion or that conservatism what
people in Egypt and elsewhere in the
Arab world wanted was to add for for any
political party in power to address
their everyday problems and when that
that when that did not happen the same
street in Egypt that brought to Islam is
to power went out to the street again to
deny that power of course in Egypt that
was mitigated and in my view that was
very unfortunate by the intervention by
the military the intervention by the
military robbed the street that power
and that very important message that it
sent to anybody who wants to exercise
you know exclusionist behavior the
minute
the minute military intervened it
mitigated that message hugely in my view
but there is another message in the
making in another country that is not
receiving much attention these days
probably because it's not it does not
have the same turmoil or the same
killings that we are witnessing in Egypt
or Syria the country where it all
started Tunisia can potentially send an
extremely important message to the rest
of the Arab world today the process in
Tunisia is far from smooth but it is
moving and the Tunisians are almost you
know have almost decided on a new
constitution by consensus and are on
their way to deciding to have new
elections in few months all the polls
today in Tunisia all the polls show that
the Islamists support has gone down to
about 13% which if you translate it into
seats means that is if if the elections
are held tomorrow the Islamists will
lose another in particular will lose
from having 90 seats in the old
Constituent Assembly to having about 70
or 65 seats in the new assembly and neda
Tunis the secular party that was only
formed two days to two years ago whose
leader is 87 years old and his accused
of being part of the old regime has
twenty-two percent in the polls today in
other words if it's still an if but if
the elections go ahead and if the
results of the polls stand and I think
they will we will have in for the first
time in the Arab world a shattering of
the notion that Islamists will not leave
power
once they come to it and if that goes on
then I think this scare tactic that Arab
governments have used all this time to
say that we are the best you know the
better of the two evils and and that you
know if you don't support us then the
Islamics will come in that notion would
be shattered if indeed we see Tunisia
going ahead as I hope it would Islamist
have lost their holiness in my view they
have lost their holiness they can no
longer today any Islamist party that
goes to elections with the slogan Islam
is the solution will will will not have
almost any support from the electorate
Islam is the solution was a good slogan
when the Islamists were outside power
now that they are inside power Islam as
a solution is not enough to solve the
people's daily problems you would think
that I'm you know very hard on the
Islamists but I'm equally hard on the
secular forces as well unfortunately the
emerging secular forces in the Arab
world today are more liberal than
democratic in fact they are downright
undemocratic and secular forces in Egypt
have shown this you know very clearly at
the first instance at the first instance
where they could see an opportunity for
them to win by other than electoral
means they chose to align with the
military practicing exactly the
exclusion is the same exclusionist
policies that they have accused the
Islamists of doing the main criticism by
secular force
of the islamists where that these people
will come to power and deny it to
anybody else and what is happening in
Egypt today is exactly the same except
that the secular forces want to come to
power and deny the right of all others
to operate that is not going to work
neither the exclusionist practices by
the Islamists nor the exclusionist
practices by the secular forces in my
view will work unfortunately until the
Arab world finds this out it's going to
take probably decades what I see
happening in the Arab world
unfortunately is a battle between the
secular elements and the Islamist
elements not a battle for pluralism and
in such a zero-sum battle the winner
takes all whoever wins that button is
going to be the new dictator of the Arab
world when the Islamists win there will
be the new dictators when the secular
forces when they will be the new
dictators as well but fortunately in my
view what the Egyptians have shown with
20 people we can differ on the numbers
with many millions of people going to
the street what the Egyptians have shown
is that from now on they are not going
to allow any exclusionist force to
dominate and that in my view is
extremely important for the process of
the development of pluralistic systems
in the Arab world even if we are only at
the beginning of such a process a
process that is going to take a long
time another issue I think that has
become extremely important to look at in
in the Arab world is the issue of
national identities look at what is
happening in North Africa and look at
what is happening in the mushroom with
all the problems that North Africa has
in Egypt in Tunisia in Libya
and in Morocco with all the these
problems at least in Egypt and Tunisia
you do have a sense of a national
identity Egyptians think of themselves
as Egyptians first and they have done so
for not just centuries maybe for
millennia long before the modern
nation-state was created they are more
or less homogeneous societies and
therefore while they will still take
maybe a decade or two until they you
know set themselves on a track to
stability and prosperity they will face
and relatively much smoother transition
than what the mushroom of the Arab world
the eastern part of the Arab world will
in the eastern part of the Arab world
most of the countries are creations of
the sykes-picot agreement in 1916 where
you know boundaries were artificially
drawn were different ethnic religious
groups were put together in countries
without any basically common sense of
identity beyond the fact that they were
all not all but mostly Arabs and mostly
Muslim and so in in in Syria in in the
last hundred years that separate us from
sykes-picot we have not seen any country
use those hundred years to forge a true
sense of national identity so that
Assyrian you know thinks of himself or
herself first as a Syrian not as a Druze
or a Christian or occurred or an Alawite
or a Sunni or what have you and the mush
wreck of the Arab world is paying the
price today in Iraq in Lebanon in Syria
and probably in other part of the world
including my own if people are not very
wise about how to treat the issue of
national
entity unless the Arab world understands
that national identities have to trump
all sub identities in my own country
Jordan is Jordan ins and Palestinians
unless it understands that we are
setting ourselves on a course which is
not far from what is happening today in
Syria in Iraq and in Lebanon and that
again brings me to the issue that is
very dear to my heart and one that I
have been talking about for some time
the Arab world is badly in need to
revisit and change its educational
policy when we talk about education
reform in the Arab world unfortunately
we still talk about putting computers in
schools we still talk about building new
schools we still talk about issues that
are important but are largely issues of
quantity the quality of education is
never talked about we never talked about
a system of values that on you know that
appreciates diversity tolerance
different point of view that teacher
skills that's critical thinking research
communication all the issues that are
essential to developing pluralistic
societies because democracy will not
thrive except in a culture that accepts
diversity and treats it as a strength
and not as a weakness in the Arab world
even though we're very diverse and even
though we talk about diversity in
practice diversity is a bad word durable
everybody is supposed to think alike
along the common cause and put aside
their differences
what's the way ahead with all these
problems well one notion is that the
transformational process that is going
on might have a better chance in
countries that have not undergone
transitions yet in the Arab world if
their leadership our wives the argument
goes that reform from above still might
offer the best solution because it is it
is a process that ensures a gradual
transition to democracy without applying
a lot of shocks to the system that of
course that is easier said than done
because ironically most of the countries
that have not undergone transitions in
the Arab world are the monarchies of the
arbor both the rich monarchies of the
Gulf and the poor monarchies of Morocco
and Jordan and how do you argue to the
leadership's in these countries that the
only way to keep their power from now on
is to share it that argument is very
difficult to internalize so while on one
hand it might offer the best chance of a
smooth transition the reality on the
ground is that none of these none of
these countries are setting themselves
on a course to gradual but serious
reform the Gulf countries the rich
monarchies are attempting to deal with
this through financial handouts
literally and they have been able to
maybe succeed at least at least until
now in slowing down the process although
you see that in Bahrain it didn't you
see that in Kuwait there are serious
some serious opposition to the monitored
to the America and even in Saudi Arabia
I think after King Abdullah leaves the
scene you're going to see some some
trouble as well but in the poor
monarchies of the
world in Morocco and Jordan the approach
so far has been to offer cosmetic reform
reform that does not really result in a
serious reform process and I'll speak
about what I mean when I talk about the
serious reform process hoping that you
know the people of these countries would
look at the countries around them would
get scared of what is happening around
them and would no longer call for reform
measures in their countries that in my
view is very short-sighted the problems
do not disappear just because of the
turmoil around them and people will
always find a way to voice their
frustration if they see that their
leadership might not be serious about a
referral process what is a successful
reform process from above what elements
should it entail in my view if it is to
be successful well the first is power
sharing you cannot talk about the
serious reform process if it does not
result in power sharing if it does not
result in strengthening the legislative
and the judicial branches at the expense
of the executive which has been
extremely dominant in the Arab world for
decades so power-sharing developing what
what you Americans call a system of
checks and balances where no power
really dominates any other and were you
you make sure that there are limits to
any power exercised by any branch on the
economic front I think it must entail
and moving away from the rentier system
that the Arab world has witnessed for so
many decades oil has been as much occurs
as a blessing in the Arab world oil has
me has meant that because money
literally grew on the ground
productivity was killed a patron system
was put in place where the governments
were able to basically exercise what I
call
royalties for loyalties so you give a
layer around you certain privileges in
return for the royalty that is not a
system that produces jobs that is not a
system that can deal with the huge
economic issues of the Arab world the
huge unemployment problem of the Arab
world where unemployment in the Arab
world is double the world's average you
are not going to do it through a system
that kills productivity and and as a
result we need to move away to a
merit-based system in order to be able
to do that and the third element is
inclusion again we speak of inclusion
but the Arab world you know if Sunnis
and Shiites cannot argue agree among
themselves and they are both you know
part of the same religion how are we to
are to agree on differences between
Islam and Christianity or between men
and women between Kurds and Arabs how
are we going to do that and so a system
that does not work for inclusion and a
sense of national identity cannot be a
serious reform process and the last
element is education as i said the arab
world has to has to shift the emphasis
from the quantity of education to the
quality and it does not need new
resources they are bored already spends
five percent of GDP on education which
is equivalent to what OECD countries
spend but it is how it spends it rather
than the amount that it spends and
finally I spoke for too long a word
about the u.s. ok what is the u.s. role
in all this what are you guys to do
about this region the short answer is
not much this is a homegrown process and
it's not a process that anybody can
affect in any significant way I'm not
suggesting that the US has not
play but I am suggesting that the US has
to be realistic about what kind of a
role it wants to play and what can it do
and not do in a process that will have
to take its course I would be happy
personally with you as encouraging the
process and not picking winners and
losers and let the region do that on
itself what the US has done in the past
is it has sided itself with winners or
losers and only to find out that people
excited with turned out to be not as
popular or stable as the u.s. thought
them to be and so my bottom line is you
know we are just the witnessing the
first of a very very this first chapter
in an extremely long book people need to
be patient I know it's not a sexy
recommendation but there are no shot no
shortcuts to democracy or stability
anywhere in the world and those who do
really want a pluralistic Arab world
will have to do it on the ground from
now on the way the Islamists have done
it before the secular elements have for
a long time accepted to be elitist
accepted to be preaching from behind
podiums maybe in the same way that I'm
doing now rather than working on the
ground developing networks developing
programs pushing for pluralistic
societies the process that is going to
take decades and that is why I believe
that if there is hope in the Arab world
it must lie with the new generation a
new generation from the Islamists and
the secular elements who believe in both
in both a civil state and in a democracy
at the same time and so that is is
entirely possible but it's going to take
time thank you very much